how to evaluate covered vaccines for a
two-year-old and a five-year-old
i'm usually pro-vaccine but apprehensive
given the novelty of the mrna mechanism
for what it's worth kids are
homeschooled i would say no i mean
in fact i think even even the
authorities who are pushing this for
absolutely everyone are saying
under i've seen actually a couple of age
ranges but i've never seen anyone
advocating for under six-year-olds yeah
and first yeah and homeschooled they're
at low risk anyway but like absolutely
not for tiny kids
they also will not have tested these
vaccines on kids so
right as far as i'm concerned kids
should be exempt for multiple reasons
yeah um not only aren't they getting
coveted but they're actually apparently
not even transmitting it
so it's not even that they're vectors
and they themselves don't get sick
but you know yes there have been a few
cases but not only are the schools
mostly coveted free
but when there are outbreaks it's going
between adults and very rarely are the
children even involved as vectors
so um like just keep it away from the
kids yeah keep it away from the kids and
really
i think we should set a fairly high age
i've seen 16.
yeah but i'm not even talking about 16
i'm talking about
how do you hedge against the kinds of
unknowns that come with a vaccine like
this
yeah one way would be to decide that the
people who are
in least danger of getting it and
suffering severe consequences
be the ones who are exempted so that um
we don't
create a catastrophe yeah i would be i
would be inclined to exempt people below
i don't know 30. well the argument then
goes
um yeah i mean this this is complicated
um maybe the group uh that should be
getting mass vaccinated first or the
so-called party animals you know the
people who are at the center of
of social groups when people you know
people like nicholas christakis do their
you know social network types of
analyses that the people who
have many many many more connections
than anyone else are the ones who are
most likely to be spreading it
if they have whatever that additional
like magic ingredient is that makes them
super spreaders which may have
nothing to do with their social behavior
and it may have everything to do
i think if it did have everything to do
with the social behavior we would know
that already though yeah
is there i i don't know is there any
indication that superspreaderness
is about some individual characteristic
rather than
a an environment that's super conducive
well this is this is
i think you just sort of asked exactly
the question that i was trying to get at
as well that
um i think
that if it was just behavioral
uh that that would be clear by now and
given that one of the few people who's
really
on this is nicholas christakis and he is
rock solid in terms of his analytical
skills and this is exactly squarely in
his wheelhouse
because he's both a sociologist who
studies social networks and also an md
and actually just came out with this
book that i haven't seen yet
this year about cobin 19 um
that we would have some sense of super
spreaders really being a behavioral
thing
and because i haven't seen that i think
that there's going to be something else
sort of
epidemiol ideological about
individuals that is making them super
spreaders
but i but i don't know and i don't i
don't think we know but
i know that i don't know my suspicion
and it may be that there's something on
top of it
is that you know you're gonna get people
who are particularly productive in terms
of
aerosolized particles yeah um because of
the moment
that they are in contact so in other
words if you imagine an event
there'll be some fraction of the
population that is at maximum
productivity of aerosolized
uh just because of the place and the
trajectory of the disease relative to
their
own body when they go to the thing when
they go to the restaurant or the party
or whatever
you know you got asymptomatic symptoms
jump productivity and then it's going to
drop off
so the prediction there is that everyone
is a super spreader for
like 12 hours in their disease
progression but most people don't hit
no i would say i would say let's take
three items that would combine
to create a super spreader event super
spreader event or individual
same thing okay you've got uh
somebody in their maximum productivity
of aerosolized particle phase
you've got um an
event that creates the conditions like a
low volume
room without proper circulation and
an activity that causes maximum
production
okay sure but you just black box the
thing we were talking about
i don't think so the first thing in that
list is you know
they're they're at their most productive
so this this fits with what i just said
which is that you
think that everyone has the capacity to
be a super spreader if they happen
if it happens to be at that point in the
trajectory of disease i
i that is certainly a hypothesis i would
not put money on that hypothesis
i think it is more likely there is
something either either
behaviorally about some people that
makes them um
that and and there's a there's a long
period during which they could be super
spreaders
or more likely there is something else
that we do not know
about their particular genome phenotype
development something that interfaces
with covet 19 particularly
that makes those individual super
spreaders regardless of what else is
true well it could even be that it isn't
genomic
and that it has to do with the accident
of what tissues
are good for fourth hypothesis yeah
it's tissues that are expect especially
likely to produce aerosolized particles
for example but i guess my point is
super spreader event
is going to be a combination of things
and two of them might have nothing to do
with idiosyncrasies absolutely but
that's why i asked you when you started
this i said are you talking about the
super spreader individual or the event
they're not the same thing
well they are because in each case
they're inherently the same because in
each case we have a super spreader
the fact of a super spreader event
which involves at least one individual
who's spreading
virus in some circumstances a super
spreader event includes a super spreader
individual but they're not the same
thing there's
it's a nested set no my point is there's
no
way to have an individual and no event
right the
individual is intersecting other people
ah well no i think that that
um these hypotheses
differ in that some of them assume that
you could be
an individual with the capacity to be a
super spreader who doesn't find the
right event
and that what you are what you are
suggesting
is that everyone no matter what if they
end up covet positive
has some period of time when if all of
the other parameters are right
will become a super spreader individual
but that that is that there is
nothing unique about them as an
individual that makes them a super
spreader i think we know that's not true
because there are you know there's a
vast range of productivity in other
words there are mild cases what do you
mean productivity of what
aerosolized particles there are lots of
cases in which somebody is expected to
produce very
few of these things over the entire
course of their disease but some of the
super spreaders have apparently been
asymptomatic
so it's not just about um you know the
current model of its aerosolized
particles and that's how you
that's how you spread it so i mean well
it's it's way more chaotic in terms of
it's it's just not clean well i'm not
saying it is
i'm a little bit doubtful about an
asymptomatic person being a super
spreader maybe you've seen
something i haven't seen i've i've seen
some stuff and i also have one very
strong anecdote
of um just an entire an entire workforce
at an office with something between 10
to 15 people
uh getting positive after one person
who had just breathed in a room for a
couple of hours without a mask and never
showed any symptoms and then
they all went in there masked um for for
a meeting for an hour
and every single one of them came out
positive within
i can't say it on air okay oh it's a
that's not a published thing no this
that so i've seen some stuff and i have
to dig it up but this this anecdote
is a situation that i know of personally
okay
um and it you know the person one of the
people involved and i were talking about
it and
um you know they were they were shocked
like no one expected that someone who
was asymptomatic could have gotten so
many people sick
and he never came down with symptoms it
never came down with symptoms and almost
none of the people
who then tested positive came down with
symptoms either and none of them got
really sick
but um all of all of them did and then
none of the people that that office
worked with
you know and they shut down completely
for two weeks and all of this and you
know they didn't
they did not get any of the their people
who they work with as
in terms of the business that they do
sick
because they were very very careful to
immediately quarantine